famous porn star Lisa Anne got dragged
out of Matt R's show at Radio City Music
Hall after NYPD put her in handcuffs
against her will for allegedly causing a
nuisance during the show which included
recording on her phone refusing to stop
talking being loud and disruptive and
even kicking police officers I did
nothing wrong Lisa Anne denied being a
problem of any kind during the show and
said quote I was dragged out of Matt R
show tonight in handcuffs stating I was
using my phone I had not used my phone I
was enjoying the show 45 minutes in
handcuffs sent to an ambulance and
released meanwhile I missed the show I
was so looking forward to I didn't touch
my phone I wanted to see that right CU
he's a friend of mine and I go to jail